boarding pixels
is the device in which
particles change into various shapes
black particles are floating in the hot
water tank
however after gazing for a while the
particles come together to form and
shape of the number
the mechanism is that
several magnets are pressed under the
water tank the computer can control the
up and down position
by moving the magnets up and down the 3d
printed particle
of magnetic resin of the surface of the
water conveyor for shape since the
particles as pixels come together to a
formal shape
there's no one shape that is the same
and
each time the shape is slightly
different
the possibility of touching is also
different from the usual pixel-based
displays
induction of moving the superior protein
on the water
makes us feel as if
we
are viewing the japanese landscape
through this artwork viewers are reminds
that our express
and inventions of the world are always
designed through the
series of the simple phenomena by
information
and that pixel are also
inevitably
material
sort of design
in the context of the superposition
it is positioned at the
overlap between artistic expression and
engineering concepts
in the meaning of the next generation of
this place or it contributes
very well to the development of
engineering
however the finished product expressed a
transient of fluctuation of forms
therefore i believe that my work is
in the oval between the two designed out
the most technology are difficult to
understand at first
sometimes
they are eventually used for the
completely different purpose than their
initial purpose
in the computer graphics artists create
projector to create new representation
of light
the artist creates a technology and i
believe that
they can lead to new creation
opportunity for the designer and
engineers
you